بالاضافه لذلك هجمنا عدد من الاهداف لحزب
الله في قيل في مارون الراس وفي جنوب
لبنان في غزه قواتنا تواصل القتال خاصه في
الجنوب خلال القتال في خانيونس
قوتنا هجموا
مخربين بين السكان ومنهم من شاركوا في
هجمات
اكتوبر المخربون بينما يختبئون في الانفاق
او في مناطق مختلفه سنصل
اليهم في عمل مشترك لاجهزه الامن ورؤساء
السلطات كانت هناك خطه لان نمكن من عوده
السكان الى البلدات لحتى 4 ك متر في قطاع
غزه على حدود قطاع غزه
البرنامج يتضمن تغيير تغييرات في الدفاع
وايضا في فرق التاه وايضا نحن في حرب
طويله اعاده السكان الجنوب والشمال هو
مجهود يتقدم حسب التقييمات العمليات اريد
ان اتوجه الى سكان الجنوب
والشمال وبسبب الصعوبه في مغادره البيت في
الاشهر الاخيره
ايضا يعني قدرتكم
وقوت كبيره ومخاوف معروفه ونحن نستمع
لكل لكل هدف
ولكل في الدفاع عن المواطنين الطريق
الطويله وفيها تحدي
وايضا علينا ان نكون ملتزمين وايضا ان
نعمل من اجلكم وان نقدم لكم الامن وان
يكون هناك قوات وايضا ان يكون هناك دفاعات
حتى اذا ما اخذ وقتا
اسئله كريد ان اسالك فيما يتعلق بجنود
الاحتياط ثلاثه اشهر في
الحرب متى يمكن ان نرى تحرير لجنود
الاحتياط في كل المناطق في يهودا والسامره
غزه وفي الشمال في المنطقه او في الفتره
القريبه هناك
برنامج نحن نبني برنامج فيما يتعلق بجنود
الاحتياط حين سنقوم بتنفيذه وايضا الجنود
الاحتياط
ممكن العوده للاستراحه وايضا اللقاء
عائلاتهم والعوده الى الحياه اليوميه
وسنبني ذلك لان الحرب طويله ومستمره وهناك
تحديات كبيره وايضا هناك تم تحرير كتيبتين
في قطع غزه وايضا الكتيبه 14 و5 خ واحد
ونحن نقوم بذلك في مختلف الجبهات هذه
عمليه طويله ونحن سنقيم ذلك وسنبلغك
بالنتائج وسنقوم بذلك هناك تحديات في
الحرب وايضا نحتاج الى قوات
الاحتياط في ما يتعلق اعاده السكان في
منطقه حدود قطاع
غزه وايضا في ما يتعلق بتفكيك
حماس انه نعمل في غزه بقوه و مصممين مصرين
وضد كل قذيفه تطلق وكل عمليه
ارهابيه والامر المهم هو كميه القوات
الموجوده في غزه وتحارب في غزه لديها مهمه
واحده وهي تفكيك حماس وهذا سيحدث في على
مراحل وهذا ياخذ وقتا وايضا يمكن ان نمكن
من عوده تدريجيه وايضا سنتحدث مع مع
القيادات المدنيه وكما تحدثت نعمل ذلك معا
ومن اجل ان نعزز الامن وايضا ان يكون هناك
امن وهكذا
سيكون في القرار الذي اتخذه اته محكمه
العدل العليا هل
هناك الفتره الاخيره نحن ن نظهر
الذين عدد من الاشخص يخلون في قطاع
غزه
هناك وثائق
واشطه السؤال هو ما
مكنس من ان يقوم بهجومه
المباغت هذه الامور
سيتم ضح من خلال التحقيق المعمق الذي
سنقوم
به
ايضا فيما يتعلق
بالجيش احد المعايير المتصل بهذا الامر ان
هناك حرب
ونحن نركز على الحرب
والجيش مصمم ومصر
وايضا هذا يتمثل في القتال وفي قوات
الاحتياط وايضا سلاح الجو والبر والبحر كل
هذه
الا من خلال الحوار الجماهيري ايضا نحن
مصممون ضد عدو
مشترك وايضا هناك تقدير لهذه القوات التي
تهدد امنها
وحياتها
وهذا يعبر عن القوه في المجتمع الاسرائيلي
وفي التحدي هذه فتره تاريخيه وفيما
يتعلق الحوادث التي ذكرت انا لا اعرف هذه
الحواد
هنا من
ناحيتنا الناطق بجيش الدفاع عندما شخص كان
في غزه وقام بشيء
غير غير سليم نحن سنعالج هذا
الامر واضا هناك
صحفيون يدخلون الى قطاع غزه
حسب الشروط
وع طب شوكرا لكم